in the early 2010 Google proudly
declared that they were done with China
they weren't gonna put up with
censorship propaganda or the CCP Google
was built to make all information easily
accessible and useful not just the
information that the CCP liked with that
Google began redirecting all search
traffic from China to an uncensored Hong
Kong version of Google for obvious
reasons the CCP was livid this was their
country and they got to set the rules
the only reason they even elected Google
in was because Google had agreed to play
by the rules years ago but now they
suddenly wanted to fight censorship hell
no that was unacceptable the CCP would
threaten to ban Google entirely if they
didn't return to their previous
Arrangement Google CEO at the time Eric
Schmidt was more than happy to do this
he had worked years to build up
relations with China and he didn't want
to lose out on the world's largest
consumer Market just the fight this
moral battle after all China wasn't
going to change their policies on
censorship just because Google left the
country they would just find someone
else who was willing to play ball by
their roles so Google might as well be
that person Google's Founders at Larry
Page and Sergey Brin however had a
different perspective they felt that
principals should always come before
profit and here it was clear that China
was asking Google to bend their
principles and this Duo was no longer
willing to do that they proudly
announced we believe strongly that in
the long term we will be better served
as shareholders and in all other ways by
a company that does a good things for
the world and with that Google left
China starting on March 31st 2010 all
Google searches from mainland China were
met with a DNS error Google had made
their stance on censorship crystal clear
and they would simply double down on the
stance in the coming years I don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that their
mark chair in China would get crushed as
a result in 2010 Google boasted a solid
29 market share in China but by the end
of 2013 this number would have dropped
to just 1.7 Google had effectively
forfeited their chances in China so
Larry and Sergey figured that they might
as well make it official starting in
2014 Google Gmail Chrome YouTube and
more would all become unavailable in
mainland China this was the legacy of
Larry Page and Sergey Brin in China but
all of this would change in 2015. in
late 2015 a new CEO would be announced
Sundar piche from very early on Sunder
would begin defending the idea of a
Google returning to China he would host
a developer conference in China and
launch a bunch of developer tools these
included
developers.google.cn
developer.android.cnn and
firebase.google.cn since then Google has
been hard at work rebuild in their
relationship with China in fact it's
alleged that at one point they were even
in building a spying tool for China so
here's how Google went from ditching
China to fight censorship to building a
surveillance tool just to get back in
the good graces of the CCP
taking a look back Google has been
flirting with the Chinese market for
well over two decades now their earliest
attempt to appeal to a Chinese audience
can be traced all the way back to
September of 2000. this is when Google
announced the ability to use google.com
in simplified and traditional Chinese
but it wasn't until Eric Schmidt took
over as a year in 2001 that Google
really started pursuing the Chinese
market China was never a top priority
though after all Google was still
working on launching a bunch of
foundational products keep in mind Gmail
and YouTuber weren't even a thing yet
but as Google's Western product stack
matured and the company went to public
Eric turned his Focus onto the Chinese
market to him it was clear that this was
the next Frontier along with India but
given that India was an open market he
would spend much of his International
effort on it cracking China fortunately
for Google China was surprisingly open
to letting Google operate in the country
as long as they stuck to some ground
rules primarily don't show stuff that
makes us look bad from the very
beginning this became a point of
controversy for anti-censorship
Advocates around the world but Larry and
Sergey had a much more optimistic
perspective they figured sure we'll have
the sensor if we enter China but we can
probably get away with less censorship
than a native Chinese search engines so
they were still effectively reducing
censorship in China overall and with
that in mind google.cn would launch in
2006 and it didn't take long for Google
to begin pushing the boundaries with
China not only did they censor last
results but when they did sense a result
they had a pop-up telling users that
results had been censored this move
pissed off the CCP as Google did it not
ask for permission before implementing
this pop-up the CCP said that this move
was like coming over for dinner and
saying I'll eat the food but I don't
like it to make things worse Google's
rebellious characteristics tended to rub
off on Tiny search engines like Baidu
really Chinese search engine said no
choice but to follow suit otherwise they
would simply bleed Market shirt to
Google while the CCP was no doubt
unhappy they also weren't willing to
push out Google so early you see much of
the Chinese internet was just about
knockoffs of American websites Google
was one of the first well-engineered
platforms to be launched in the country
so it was in their best interest to keep
Google around as they brought in a
substantial amount of knowledge funding
and talent so the CCP bit their tongue
and they let Google carry on with their
Shenanigans but in the end it seemed
like Google was winning they were
successfully fighting Chinese censorship
by expanding to China not to mention
they were making a bunch of money by
late 2009 Google controlled over a third
of the Chinese search Market but then if
things were going so well what happened
ironically it wasn't actually censorship
concerns that pushed Google out of China
for the most part China was letting
Google have their way when it came to
pushing the boundaries the factor that
actually pushed out Google was Chinese
greed remember how we talked about the
CCP wanting Google to help develop
China's tech industry well that was
going pretty well but China wanted more
progress China didn't want to wait out
the full cycle of Engineers working at
Google they're not leaving Google and
then starting their own companies and
then hiring more Chinese engineers and
training them and so on it would take
several years if not decades for this to
naturally play out and for Google's
knowledge to spread across the Chinese
tech industry so China figured why wait
that long when we can just have it now
and with that China would launch
operation Aurora starting in mid-2009
China would start a massive Cyber attack
not just against Google but against most
of the American tech industry this
included companies on like Yahoo Adobe
Juniper Networks and even Morgan Stanley
their target at each of these firms was
their source code which was ironically
something that these firms didn't really
protect they were spending billions on
protecting personal data Financial
profiles and credit card numbers but
they had never considered protecting
their source code their secret sauce was
really their branding positioning and
user base not their source code I mean
just because you or me have Google
source code it doesn't mean that will
become the next to Google for China
however that was actually the case with
the source code of these companies the
CCP could create their own Tech Giants
that their citizens would have to use
this of course put off Google but it
didn't push them over the edge just yet
the reality was that many of their
biggest projects like Android and chrome
were already open source so it's not
like China's told too much but they were
by by no means done next the CCP would
Target Google's intellectual property
which was much more valuable but even
this didn't push Google over the edge
the nail in the coffin came soon after
though when the CCP started hacking him
into Gmail but wait a minute there's
nothing special about the Gmail if
Google was willing to overlook
intellectual property theft why did they
care so much about Gmail well it wasn't
for the source code the CCP couldn't
care less about the source code of an
email platform what they were really
after was human rights activists they
were looking to identify the individuals
behind a problematic email addresses so
that they could go ahead and off them
this was the finals draw Google had had
it with the CCP and their Antics on
January 12 2010 they would publicly
State we have decided we are no longer
willing to continue censoring our
results on google.tn and so over the
next few weeks we will be discussing
with the Chinese government the bases on
in which we could operate an unfiltered
search engine within the law if at all
this leads us to the dramatic withdrawal
that we detailed it at the beginning of
the video but as we also mentioned this
withdrawal didn't last forever
the bottom line was that Google didn't
realize how independent China's tech
industry had become since their entry
and instead of getting crushed by
censorship the Chinese tech industry
actually blew up in their early 2010s
without Google companies like xiaomi
tensioned Alibaba Huawei Baidu and
jd.com were crushing it growing to
multi-deck a billion if not multi 100
billion dollar valuations
unlike Google these companies were
willing to play by any and all rules set
by the CCP you could say that Google had
a bit of fomo but under Larry's
leadership Google wasn't willing to
backtrack on her decision to leave China
all of this would change when Sunder
pichai took over though it's not that
Sunder is evil or that he loved the CCP
but as a non-founder CEO he did have the
pressure to constantly please
shareholders he couldn't just ignore
them like most Founders do and from his
perspective it the easiest way to
continue growth was attacking the
Chinese market this is exactly what
Apple was doing and they were getting
extraordinary results so Sunder started
off by appealing to Chinese developers
he would host a developer conference in
China at the end of 2016 where a bunch
of chinese-specific developmentals would
be announced but he wasn't happy with
just this what he really wanted was to
bring back Google search to China but
given their dramatic exit China wasn't
exactly ecstatic to let them back in not
to mention they no longer needed Google
either so Google had to convince China
to let them back in it which brings us
to project dragonfly on the surface
dragonfly was just a censored version of
Google Search but behind the scenes it
was a lot more nefarious according to
the intercept the project allegedly
until the collecting people's search
history location history and other
private data and sharing it all with the
Chinese company presumably for
surveillance purposes when this got
leaked to the media though Google not
only had to deal with a bunch of public
backlash but also a bunch of internal
protests so unsurprisingly they would
kill their project just a few months
later at the end of 2018.
since all of this took place privacy has
become a top concern when it comes to
Big tech companies so Sunder has very
much shifted his tone when it comes to
China she has since clarified that the
company has no plans of relaunching in
China who knows though with the current
recession and stagnating growth China
may very well be something that Google
considers once again but the truth is
that whether they re-enter China or not
they have already lost the CCP the
reality is that the CCP brilliantly
played Google they lured them in with
the appeal of a large consumer market
then they stole all of your source code
and IP and finally they pushed them out
never to return meanwhile Google was led
to believe that they were doing the
moral thing by stepping out of China
when in reality they were just making
room for up-and-coming Chinese companies
to take their place and today it's
google.wantage China not the other way
around and that's the sad story of
Google China do you think Google should
have loved China comment that down below
also drop a like if you would like to
see more Tech stories and of course
consider checking out our Discord
community so just after video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the
next one
thank you